[Musique]
bonjour à tous et ravi de vous retrouver
pour politique à table comme chaque
semaine sur LCP autour d'un plat d'un
dessert et surtout d'un invité et cette
semaine nous recevons sopia Haram
bonjour bour et merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation merci pour l'invitation
je suis ravie et avec nous pour cette
émission et pour la présenter
Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre
bonjour bgit bonjour Sophia RAM bonjour
Jean-Pierre vous êtes humoriste
comédienne chroniqueuse sur France
interre depuis 2008 on peut vous écouter
le lundi matin à 8h55 il faut être déjà
bien réveillé parce qu'avec vous ça fuse
dans tous les coins un festival de Vann
où le RN est Rabillé en majesté et
l'islam radical votre cible privilégiée
on peut aussi vous voir au théâtre en ce
moment au studio des Champs-Élysées pour
le monde d'après où vous êtes à la
recherche d'une gauche en perdition vous
désespérez d'une gauche
complaisante abrité derrière sa
bienpensance vous avez des origines
marocaines par vos parents mais vous
avez été élevé à trappe alors symbole
d'intégration réussie jusque dans
l'assiette ou parce que vous êtes issu
d'une frattererie de six enfants où les
deux parents bossent et où
définitivement et bien on n pas le temps
de se prendre la tête avec le menu alors
on a fait simple Jean-Pierre simple
simplissime je dirais des pâtes à la
sauce tomate et un M au chocolat en
dessert dans le dessous des plats
peut-on rire et manger nous vous
emmenons au pan àart café pour une série
de standup dans les pieds dans le plat
le succès de la cuisine végétarienne les
restaurants rivalisent d'imagination
pour nous faire saliver avec des
recettes au goût de viande mais sans
viande reportage à suivre allez on passe
à table tout de suite cuisine et
confidence quand on vous a invité à
politique à table Sophia RAM c'est le
mot politique qui a fait tilte chez vous
plus que le mot à table faut dire que
vous êtes très politique avec des
convictions on l'a entendu un cap lacard
républicaine résolument de gauche alors
que lorsqu'on passe à table vous n'avez
pas vraiment de repère pas de boussole
sûr étonnant d'ailleurs de la part d'une
fille de chef cuisinier j'ai lu qu'étant
enfant vous aviez une passion pour le
beurre on aurait pu imaginer Brigitte
une spécialité normande mais pas du tout
le beurre est passé à la trappe vous
nous dites que votre plat préféré c'est
le rifsa une recette marocaine fam avec
des lentilles et du poulet quoi du
poulet j'ai lu que vous étiez
végétarienne allez comprendre finalement
votre choix s'est porté sur des pâtes à
la tomate basique de chez basique je me
suis dit que c'était histoire de rendre
hommage à l'Italie votre trème Patrick
ulinière après la France et le Maroc
mais là encore pas vraiment je découvre
que vous n'avez jamais mis les pieds
dans la botte bref à table vous êtes une
énigme et aussi mais ça c'est vous qui
le dites une jouisseuse mais dites-moi
alors pourquoi ces pâtes à la tomate
sont si glamour pour vous alors je je
suis allée en Italie ah depuis mais je
suis allé souvent en Italie j'ai mais si
on vous a menti ah bah moi j'ai cru j'ai
lu alors pe mal al c'est un très papier
fake
newsake non non j'aime beaucoup l'Italie
je connais pas le sud de l'Italie je
connais le nord de l'Italie alors que
j'aime beaucoup la cuisine sarde mais le
nord de l'Italie j'aime l'Italie et
pourquoi j'ai choisi les pâtes c'était
ça la question à laquelle je dois répond
à la tomate parce que je trve quand on
est jouisseuse à table on choisit des
pâtes à la tomate c'est le plat le plus
rassurant pour moi ah je trouve ça
sécurisant et Doud ouais vraent cable
c'est un moment qui vous rassure c'est
un moment privilégi pour vous la table
alors ça peut ça c'est c'est plein de
choses parfois je parfois j'avoue j'ai
pas le temps alors je mange par
nécessité mais quand j'arrive quelque
part et que je me dis qu'est-ce que je
qu'est-ce que j'ai envie de manger pour
pour me sentir bien c'est des pâtes et
des pâtes à la sauce tomate qu'est-ce
qui vous rassure dans ces pâtes à la
tomate c'est tellement bon ah ça dépend
vous TR vous avez l'air sceptique vous
avez pas vous avez l'air hyper déçu vous
ariez préféré que que je choisisse autre
chose mais je vous assure je peux faire
une semaine à manger tous les midis des
pâtes à la sauce tomate et ça me lassera
jamais alors on va les goûter parce que
vous allez nous dire si elles sont aussi
bonnes que vos pâtes à la Tom j'ai une
expertise quand même he oui c'est ça je
pense que alors c'est pas les miennes
plus que celles que je peux manger au
restaurant ou ou qu'on fait je suis pas
une excellente cuisinière non plus hein
faut parler je dis qu'elle est elle est
très maline s par que qu'est-ce qu'elle
a pris un petit pull noir oui alors que
vous Jean-Pierre vous avez joué la
chemise blanche et je trouve que vous
êtes joueur personnellement surtout vous
voulez me poser une question non mais je
voulais savoir alors TR alors déjà est
moi j'ai goûté elles sont très bonnes
elles sont très bonnes elles sont très
bonnes on aurait bien aimé un peu de
parmesan petit des petites critiques
voilà voilà voil comment vous les faites
vous par exemple alors alors parce qu'il
y a une recette peut-être moi je mets
beaucoup d'ail beaucoup beaucoup d'ail
parce que l'ail c'est c'est c'est de
l'amour et ouais non là j'aime bien
quand c'est relevé aussi un peu je peux
mettre un peu de pp l'ail un peu confit
un peu en chemise là
non fait revenir l'ail dans le oua ouais
c'est bien aillé dans l'huile d'olive et
et des tomates j'aime bien la pulpe de
tomate ceris et on trouve ça c'est un
petit peu plus sucré c'est ça ou oui
parce que le petit goût de sucre dans la
tomate et pour pour retirer l'acidité et
voilà puis on met un tout petit peu de
bouillon de l'eau des pâtes là pour
mettre dedans très bien ah l'italienne
alors est-ce que vous les faites revenir
dans la poêle vraiment comme les oui
évidemment Brigit que vous m'avez pris
pour une débutante novice et al denté
c'est combien de temps ah bah al dent ça
dépend des pâtes ça c'est des pâtes
fraîches donc je pense que c'est très
très peu de cuisson mais quand on prend
des pâtes sèches si on vous indique 13
minutes il faut mettre 11 un petit peu
moins voilà oui viment moins 11 10 11
ouais et après pour les faire revenir un
peu dans la sauce ouais alors Brigit
elle m'a complètement spoilé trois
choses à parce que j'avais moi j'avais
préparé faire les meilleures pâtes à la
tomate oua mais alors
question vous avez raison parce que vous
auriez pu dire des choses qui était
fausse mais là je vais faire que dire ce
que vous avez dit donc on va aller très
vite moi j'aurais plutôt pris des
taglionis parce que j'aime bien parce
que la sauce peut se lever à l'intérieur
de ces gros tubes effectivement pour les
faire al dent elle a raison sopia Haram
il faut ne pas respecter la le temps de
cuisson indiqué sur la la boîte il faut
aller plutôt toujours garder de l'eau de
cuisson pourquoi parce que l'eau de
cuisson elle contient un peu de l'amidon
des pâtes lorsqueon la remettra cette
eau de cuisson ça fera un peu de liant
alors effectivement dans une poêle vous
faites revenir une grosse gousse d'ail
vous mettez vos vos pâtes des es jamais
Paron pas de bon Tom enance P et pas
l'hiver surtout jeier bon Tom et
privilégier les marques italiennes on
trouve des tomates qui ont du goût qui
sont très bonnes pour faire des pâtes à
l'italiennes et à la fin on fait ce qu'a
dit Sopi on remue tout moi je mets
quelques feuilles de basilic et allez ce
que vous n'avez pas dit pour un petit
peu une petite touche gourmande moi je
mets des petits copos de scaroza vous
savez
Laz la Moza fum ça ça donne une petite
couche et c'est très bon voilà merci
Jean-Pierre pour cette très bonne
recette connais bien les Patat à la
tomate hein sopia vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est rassurant les pâtes à la
tomate ça veut dire qu'en fait vous vous
retrouvez quasiment la même recette
partout où vous allez enfin il y a peu
de variantes finalement sur cette
recette bon il peut y en avoir un tout
petit peu mais c'est pas c'est pas
foufou enfin je veux dire les pâes à
qu'on va manger quand on trouve des pâes
à c'est ça exactement et ouais je crois
que c'est ça je crois que c'est c'est en
ça que c'est rassurant c'estàd que il y
a pas de de de de prise de risque parce
que j'imagine que quand on va manger je
dis n'importe quoi une blanquette de
veau d'une maison à l'autre ce sera pas
la même recette alors que des pâtes à la
sauce tomate avec ou sans ail avec ou
sans basilic a peu de chance il y a peu
de chance de se varer quoi mais c'est
votre nature ça de pas prendre de risque
ah non moi j'en prends mais alors au
niveau de l'assiette il faut niveau de
l'assiette fa c'est juste à ce momentl
qu'on se rassure on en prend
suffisamment partout ailleurs pour
pouvoir avoir des endroits dans lesquels
on est on est confort d'accord est-ce
que vous avez fait ramener des pâtes à
la tomate parce qu'elles étaient trop
cuites par exemple dans un restaurant
vous ne vous permettez pas ce genre de
chose non je fais pas ça moi j'avais des
des amis italiens qui faisaient ça
brégite cu là les faisait ramener en
cuisine dans les restaurants français
j'avais une belle mère qui supportait
pas les pâes al denté donc on on se on
se grugeait l'une et l'autre sur le sur
le chrono elle elle mettait 13 minutes
moi je mettais je mettais neuf et donc
il y en avait une qui passait derrière
l'autre pour pour changer le chrono
parce qu'on était vraiment il faut
savoir aldente c'est presque un peu dur
pour nous hein pour nous Français c'est
c'est presque un petit peu ouais un trop
al denté c'est ça peut être un peu
dérangeant mais alors c'est meilleur
pour la santé moins les pâtes sont
cuites mieux on digère le le fameux
gluten qui peut provoquer quelques
intolérances il vaut mieux les manger
moins cuites possible ben moi je bois
vos paroles je suis ravie vous entendre
parce que moi j'aime bien quand elles
sont vraiment pas trop cuites alors vous
vous aimez cuisiner ou pas pas tellement
pas
tellement mince al mais ouais fille de
cuisinier en fait ça me votre père ne
vous a rien transmis si j'adorais être
avec lui dans la cuisine regarder
cuisiner ça sentait j'étais tout le
temps dans la cuisine avec lui regarda
et faire je trouvais ça merveilleux euh
et j'ai du mal à stabiliser des recettes
pour tout vous dire c'est que je je vais
réussir un truc et puis la fois d'après
je vais me lancer et ça va être très
dcevant ça va être moins bien et donc ça
voilà je je suis très déçu je qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire stabilisé vous suivez
pas assez bien la recette jamais
jamais je sais mais je suis trop trop
indiscipliné pour ça je crois la cuisine
c'est c'est comme la enfin la pâtisserie
a plus forte raison c'est un truc voilà
il faut vraiment être sérieux rigoureux
ouais moi je suis peu plus fantaisiste
j'aime bien changer un ingrédient par un
autre oh bah tiens il y a pas de il y a
pas de ça je vais mettre autre chose
donc à arrivrivée c'est mauvais
franchement mauvais complètement raté
comment ça complètement raté j'ai il y a
eu des drames il y a eu des drames ah
oui oui oui j'ai des copains qui sont
venus dîner on veulent plus revenir bah
il préfèrent qu'on commande des pizzas
enfin voilà c'est plus rassurant pour
eux non il y a eu des vrais ratés mais
votre homme cuisine aussi ouais c'est
lui qui c'est lui qui qui ti alors lui
il est très fort ou pas à table il est
il est plutôt fort ouais ouais de plus
en plus il a eu pareil il on part de
très très loin il était vraiment mauvais
et mais j'ai mais comme je suis
amoureuse je l'ai laissé faire et je lu
c'est intéressant et et puis petit à
petit et puis le confinement a aidé ah
oui le confinement a aidé autolangi nous
a nous a aussi beaucoup aidé ouais voilà
les livres de cuisine qu'on nous a
offert les autolingi c'est merveilleux
pour cuisiner les légumes on adore ça
c'est dingue le succès d'autolingi BR il
y a pas unité qui n parle pas d' ouais
ouais c'est simple il y a plein
d'ingrédients pas toujours facile à trou
oui simple mais Jérusalem mais pas si
simple à l'intérieur effectivement sont
quand même assez travaillé il y a pas
mal d'ingrédi ouais mais après c'est
aussi le c'est c'est la place que
prennent les légumes dans la cuisine
aujourd'hui grâce à grâce à autolingi
c'estàdire que le choufleur était pas
hyper populaire non plus quand on vous
disait je vais vous jeis vous servir un
petit chou-fleur
ça faisait pas rêver forcé non c'était
un peu répulsif là maintenant un
chou-fleur façon autolengi ça se la pète
un peu quoi vous cuisinez à quatre mains
parce que c'est pas facile de de
partager la cuisine dans un coup couple
je trouve il y a toujours qu qui pr le
leadership j'aime bien les je je suis un
petit peu la petites mains ouais j'ai
plus je voilà je coupe je fais la
vaisselle je range le truc moi j'aime
bien voilà ça me va bien je je goûte je
goûte je dis si c'est si c'est assez
salé pas salé voilà ça me va bien vous
avez aussi des des origines marocaines
alors les tajines les couscous et tout
ça est-ce que vous en faites est-ce que
vous avez une recette familiale ou pas
on en a on en a plein voors moi j'ai un
vrai problème c'est que j'aimais le
beurre quand j'étais petite et je pense
que j'en ai un peu abusé ce qui fait que
j'aime plus tellement manger gras ah oui
ce qui fait que je fais un couscous
light qui déprime mon père au plus haut
point mon couscous est beaucoup trop
light pour être un vrai couscous
homologué couscous familial à RAM donc
voilà je m'arrange un peu avec tout ça
mais par exemple le dimancheoir on n pas
envie de cuisiner pas envie un petit
agagine avec juste de la sauce tomate
euh je fais des petites boulettes de
viande pour mon fils et mon mari moi je
mange pas de viande je leur fais des
boulettes de viande et on casse des œufs
dans la sauce tomate et ça c'est
délicieux ça c'est c'est super bon et ça
sent bon dans la maison ça sent les
oignons revenus et tout ça c'est la
cannelle parfois alors vousimz pas
j'adore la canelle mais pas dans celuià
alors le Rif ça dont on je parlé tout à
l'heure moi j'ai jamais comment ça se
prononce ça ça va pas jean-pierreation
non F ça F ça mais il y a pas il y a pas
de voyelle donc fa ça c'est un plat
familial qu'on sert aux femmes qui
viennent d'avoir un bébé donc chez nous
c'est c'est une tradition parce que les
lentilles on sait que c'est bon pour les
femmes qui qui allit et cetera donc on
le sait maintenant il y a il y a aussi
toute cette toute cette science là mais
c'est c'est une tradition chez nous
alors c'est fait avec les galettes vous
savez less les galettes marocaines
qu'onert au petit-déjeuner au Maroc euh
enfin qui sont marocaines qui partout au
au Maghreb ouais et on les découpe en
petits morceaux donc dans un plat et le
bouillon fait fait à base d'oignon plein
d'épices des lentilles et du poulet et
on sert tout ça sur le sur les sur les
galettes coupées on peut le manger dans
des certains rest en Maroc j'ai jamais
vu à la carte ce plat c'est très rare
parce que c'est vraiment un plat
familial j'ai trouvé euh du côté de
pasteur il y a une petite cantine j'ai
oublié le nom ça me reviendra tout à
l'heure je vous l'enverrai pour que vous
le mettiez sur le site et où ils font
des brunch avec F ça c'est merveilleux
ouais mais il faut peut-être pas que je
le dise parce qu'après il y aura plus il
y aura trop de monde ouais vous vous le
préparez à la maison alors ouais je sais
le faire j'ai surtout mon mari qui a
appris à le faire et qui le fait voilà
d'accord mais alors vous sans le poulet
du coup moi ça me dérange pas qu'il a du
poulet mais je le mange pas oui c'est
çaou ça ê avec c'est pas
grave taliban à ce point-l donc voilà
non non non je mange juste pas de viande
alors on va voir si vous êtes vraiment
incollable c'est le quiz
ou alors Sophia ayant vécu à traape vous
avez donc été une trapiste non donné aux
habitants mais aussi à des moine
sauriez-vous nous dire sopia RAM si ses
affirmations sur l'alimentation par le
passé des moines sont vraies ou fausses
par le passé parce qu'ensuite il y a eu
quelques évolutions mais voilà alors
dans les monastères la consommation du
vin était
permis je dirais que oui non faux et au
fil du temps les moines avaient
tellement envie de boire un petit coup
de rouge que on leur a permis de boire
mettre un peu de vin mais couper avec de
l'eau mais le vin 100 % vin
étaitb mais parce qu'ils sont connus
pour la bière TR non non mais c'est vrai
bonne réflexion ensuite ils ont eu le
droit de boire la bière voilà qu' on
pensait que ça pouvait d'abord permettre
de de de ne pas user trop d'eau et mais
le vin était proscrit au départ la
viande était desstinée au sol
malade je vais dire oui oui vrai parce
qu'on considérit que c'était des
protéines et il fallait la donner au
malad et souvent il y avait pas assez de
viande parce que les moines se
nourrissaient de leur jardin il y avait
pas forcément suffisamment de bêtes ou
de poissons pour nourrir l'ensemble du
monastère les seuls poissons que les
trapistes pouvaient consommer étaient
des poissons d'eau
douce
pourquoi pas ou oui parce que ça rejoint
ce que je viens de dire s'il avait un
étan près du monastère il pouvait manger
les poisson en général ils étaient pas
près de la mer donc il mangeaient pas de
poisson et au 12e siècle les moines
cisterciens de clairveau mangeaient des
herbes
cuite ouais
oui c'est pas fou fou comme truc c'est
très très bon les herbes alors les
herbes cuites alors deuxème quiz un de
vos anciens spectacles s'appelait la
crise de aïe sans sans UF oui c'était
sans UF ouais à table après quelques
excès on risque la crise de foi avec un
uf alors sauriez-vous nous dire si ces
aliments sont conseillés en cas de
trouble a le radinoir Oui ou nonou oui
mais oui mais oui le rad du NO très très
bien le rad du NO très connu B le pain
non non bon non pas le pain pas le c'est
fort he Sophia r c'est fort très santé
moi euh alors là le coca
alors le coca vous voulez qu'on rentre
dans les détails du tout après une
gastro c'est recommandé mais sans les
bulles voilà c'est ça donc donc là c'est
non donc c'est
ou parce que pas de soda pas de sucre en
fa fa
Cocat un myth ça boire un coca après une
gastro en tous les
cas rass mais c'est plus pour la
réhydratation je crois que c'est une
question BO y a de la caféine qui peut
remuscler un peu alors qu'on est faible
après une Gast peut-être pour ça mieux
éviter la Gastr aliment l'asperge est-ce
que c'est conseillé en cas de trouble
l'asperge j'ai jamais entendu ça alors
je dirais non et ben moi j'aurais dit
comme vous mais en fait c'est
oui rajouter
dansop on peut le rajouter pour la
prochaine crise de
fois très bien voilà alors je ne sais
pas si le Koucha est conseillé en cas de
crise de foie c'est ce que vous nous
avez demandé alors le combcha c'est une
boisson qui est fermentée à base de thé
acidulé finement pétillante sans alcool
bien sûr bio et on peut y trou on
trouver de différentes saveurs donc il y
a thé vert thé noir Ginger gingembre
agrume framboise citron ou menthe là
c'est au thé vert est-ce que ça vous
plaît trèson ah ouais il est vraiment
très bon celui-là ouais et vous avez
l'habitude d'en boire ouais j'aime bien
ça mais parce que j'aime j'aime pas
l'alcool je bois pas par goût je trouve
ça pas bon au goût et en soirée souvent
c'est pénible quand on dit qu'on aime
pas l'alcool donc je dis je prendrai
bien un comoucha ou j'arrive avec ma
bouteille de Koucha et ça me donne une
espèce de consistance d'adulte et j'ai
ce truc j'ai un verre avec un truc qui a
la couleur d'un whisky et donc c'est pas
mal c'est un peu comme dans le Père Noël
et uneure quoi vous venez avec votre
bout ma bouteille que pour moi et c'est
vrai que c'est c'est un truc qui
questionne c'est que il y a quand on dit
qu'on boit pas les gens vous regarde un
peu triste pour
vous vie doit être très triste
rassurez-moi ça vous le buvez en fait
pour faire la maline devant les convives
mais à table est-ce qu'on peut boire du
comme ça à table à table je vois de
l'eau et
j'aime bien boire des boissons chaudes
moi je bois beaucoup d'infusion vous
avez fait des yeux un peu bizarres vous
avez été trèsusion à table il a pas
réussi à garder son poker TR voir une
nuit calme en
mangeant ça paraîz ou moi ça me dérange
pas asiatique un peu j'aime l'eau chaude
j'aime boire l'eau
chaude qui est retiré de leur contexte
sont tellement j'aime l'eau chaude la
douche oui mais bors donc plutôt de
l'eau plutôt de l'eau ouais de l'eau ou
ouis mais ça c'est honnêtement c'est
assz bon on a l'impression de se faire
du bien çaêtre bon après une crise de
doit dire que c'est bon pour la santé
c'est tellement dégueulasse ah
non j'ai senti ça dans la dans la
remarque dans le visage de non non pas
du tout alors c'est souvent autour de la
table ou à l'occasion d'un déjeuner et
bien que ce que se raconte les
meilleures histoires que ce nous parfois
des deals politiques c'est la breve de
comptoir sopia Haram on vous a demandé
de réfléchir à une anecdote politique
autour d'un repas ou autre si vous avez
laquelle vous avez envie de nous
raconter alors politique j'avais pas
ouais donc je me suis dit que comme on
parlait de de nourriture et souvent
quand on me demande ce que je mange ce
que je mange pas je suis obligée de
faire une petite liste parce que depuis
quelques années j'ai découvert que
j'avais des allergies et avant de le
savoir j'avais mangé on était chez des
amis et j'avais mangé à Saint-Malo du
crabe et j'avais trouvé ça très bon j'en
avais déjà mangé par le passé mais alors
là c'était c'était régalé et alors en
fin de pas tout à coup mes paupières se
sont mises à enfler mon nez s'est mis à
enfler ma bouche s mise à enfler et là
les gens me
regardaient voyez dans les Quates
fantastiques l'homme de pierre mais ça
donnait ça ça JIS un visage un peu
granuleux et tout à coup je me suis mise
à faire des et là on a compris que
c'était assez grave donc j'ai fait un
odème de kink quand je suis arrivé aux
urgences il y avait tellement de monde
que j'ai eu envie de faire demi-tour et
c'est l'infirmier de garde qui m'a
aperçu et qui m'a attrapé qui m'a emmené
dans un box ouais mais donc j'ai
découvert à cette occasion là qu'un des
trucs que j'aimais vraiment à l'époque
je mangeais je mangeais des fruits de
mer et j'aimais le le crabe on m'a
expliqué qu'il fallait pas que je mange
et alors là j'ai commencé à développer
des tas d'allergies et donc quand je
quand je dois dire aux gens ce que je ne
mange pas donc je ne mange pas de viande
mais je mange pas de crabe je mange pas
de langousste je ne mange pas de
langoustine et il y a un autre truc et
j'ai oublié quoi et c'est pas bien
d'oublier bon tout les coquillages et
tout tout ça vous mangez pas les Saint
Jacques les ça va ça va mais alors
j'aime bien parce
que les crevettes grises ça va pas fort
mais alors que les crevettes oui bon
allez savoir pourquoi et puis par
exemple tout ce qui est hitre non ou
quand c'est cru non fréquent pasodeou
mais c'est intéressant vous avez fait
quoi vous avez fait des tests vous êtes
allé voir quelqu'un qui a dit voilà
exactement qui a pu décrire tous les
tous les aliments et après j'ai fait des
tests avec j'ai toujours sur moi un
spray d'adrénaline et de quoi me faire
des picur par que que je fais aussi des
allergies à des médicaments la fille
hyper chiante dans la vie mais ouais
ouais c'est compliqué parce encore
peut-être encore les aliments vous ne
soupsonne pas voilà et en plus on peut
développer exactement et on peut
développer des allergies plus tard c'est
terrible et quand on est allergique
c'est pour la vie en fait on non non
parce que c'est arrivé tard et ça peut
dispar vous avez pas très envie d'
manger bah jouer comme ça tout de suite
là ou alors on peut se marrer hein faut
filmer en je sais pas il peut y avoir un
truc mais justement alors on a un petit
peu de C pour vous du CR mais le CR vous
en mangez avant et ça s'est déclaré o
c'est bizarre non rien à voir avec Sam
Malo sûr non bien sûr j'ai compris mais
pour les conv
peut-être non plus la variété du
crors non maintenant si si si si vous me
faites des pâtes au crab et que je vous
dis non non je mange pas le crabe et
vous me dites non non mais il y en a n
pas c'était c'était à part et que ça a
touché je vais faire une réaction
allergique
oui c'est pas juste oui c'est rigolo à
voir comme ça mais pas pour les autes
moi je rigole moins mais en revanche
j'ai mangé du Homar et je ne suis pas
allergique ah le Homar ça passe
bizarrement oui CR très bien donc Homar
a tous les REP la fille qui coûte cher
le caviar ça va aussi j'en ai goûté très
très tardivement et pass et c'est bah
ouais pareil avec le spray d'adrénaline
à côté je me suis dit il faut que je
goûte et pourvu que j'aime pas ça et en
fait j'ai trouvé ça bon et j'ai pas fait
d'allergie bon ben alors on continue
vous savez quoi m'offrir si vous voulez
me faire plaisir F plaisir alors à Paris
il y a des restaurants qui sont pas
comme les autres la bas plus n'est pas
forcément dans l'assiette c'est le
dessous des
plats alors on vous emmène passer la
soirée au panamart café dans ce resto
parisien la carte est variée et surtout
fê maison mais si on y vient c'est aussi
pour rire après le dîner la soirée
continue place au standup dans ce coméy
club où se produisent comi en herbe
comme les plus réputé c'est un reportage
de Dario borgognot et mari de
Vauchel je vais le faire le Paname
faites-moi du
bruit bienvenue au Panam café ici plus
besoin de choisir entre rire et manger
d'un côté les
cuisines et de l'autre une scène
mythique du standup parisien le concept
avant le spectacle un menu complet fait
maison alors les
entrées moi je prend le gra oui on fait
le repas avant pour pas déranger les
humoristes parce que les gens sont pas
concentrés sur sur le les blagues plus
concentré sur l'assiette donc on fait
d'abord le restaurant et après la
rigolade on rigole mieux le ventrepin on
mange super bien franchement c'est super
bon et et puis ben c'est cool aussi de
pouvoir enchaîner du coup sur une soirée
un peu tranquille on semaine en plus et
d'aller voir un spectacle d'humoriste
enfin c'est pas tous les jours que ça
arrive donc toutes les TR s'est mis
d'accord sur le fait que céit une super
idée et qu'on avait envie de vivre ça ce
soir ouais je pense qu'on va bien se
marer des
Chan et pour réussir à les faire rire
sous leurs pieds dans les loges les
artistes finalisent leur sketch je testé
un petit truc moi sur le racisme
contrairement à son public l'humoriste
est sur scène le ventre vide parce que
je joue avec mes trips et ça va se
mélanger donc je je mange après quand tu
fais une scène et ça marche très très
bien tu es heureux tu manges sauf si tu
bides tu manges
[Applaudissements]
aussi
je me rappelle mon premier test
d'évaluation langue française le mec il
m'a félicité quand même il m'a dit tu
parles super bien italien mon frère
continue comme ça bruit pour s'il vous
plît et après l'heure de spectacle les
humoristes se retrouvent enfin à table
pour découvrir une carte sans cesse
renouvelé je vois que ils font plein
d'effort comme nous on essaie toujours
de d'améliorer nos sket il s toujours
améliorer parce qu'il y a plein de
clients aussi de gens Vinent
spécialement pour manger ici et Panam ça
devient un an aujourd'hui donc ils
peuvent pas se permettre d'avoir une
cuisine approximative c'est toujours
pointu comme cuisine depuis son
lancement en 2008 le Panam a vu des
concurrents ouvrir avec la même formule
mais avec d'autres éclats de
rire Sophia RAM vous connaissez le
panamar café vous y avez joué non j'y ai
pas joué mais je connais évidemment
ouais c'est un nom qu'on connaît bien
j'y suis jamais allé pour être tout à
fait sincère et c'est vrai qu'il a l'air
d'y avoir une super ambiance et ça donne
vraiment l' assez sympa vous avez déjà
joué vous dans des resto ou des toutes
petites sales
quand j'ai démarré j'ai démarré dans un
bar moi donc les gens buvaient des
bières et on jouait gratuitement et on
faisait passer un chapeau à la fin pour
pour avoir un peu de sous pour avoir un
peu de sous pour payer le régisseur ou
la régisseuse qui était là ouais ouais
non non quand on démar les gens ils
mangeaient devant vous comme ça ils vous
regard ouais ouais il y avait même des
gens derrière le rideau qui fêtaient le
match de rugby qui venait de se terminer
ououi ça c'était c'était folklorique et
alors c'est difficile de de se
concentrer tout c'est formateur vraiment
c'est formateur moi je trouve que c'est
c'est des conditions surtout au début on
est on est en en insécurité et à la fois
si on arrive à à à esquisser des rires à
avoir des rires dans la dans le public
c'est qu'on a réussi quelque chose c'est
que les gens ils sont tout près de vous
donc en fait vous les voyez réagir donc
si si la fait un bid là vous voyez tout
de suite quoi ouis mais mais c'est c'est
très juste et à la fois les gens qui
mangent c'est il y a il y a des cabarets
il y a des choses comme ça ça a toujours
existé moi j'avoue que sur mes
spectacles je trouve pas que ça s prête
mais je pense que sur certains
spectacles où on n pas besoin d'une
attention à 100 % d'avoir un public trop
captif ça peut ça ça peut ça peut se
faire ça peut se faire mais vous avez
vraiment fait du vrai standtinop au sens
littéral du terme on raconte un peu sa
vie à la première personne non c'est
plutôt vous plutôt été dans des sketchs
un peu écrits JIS mon premier spectacle
c'était c'était un HCl dans une école
maternelle enfin je jouais tous les
personnage d'une cellule de soutien
psychologique et ouais vous avez
un une communication non non verbale
très fort avec un visage qui est hyper
[Rires]
expressif on l' JIS dit vous l'avez pas
vu ce spectacle là visiblement il faut
il faut les contrechamps sur vous s'il
vous plaît alors bon est-ce qu'il a
raison le comic est-ce qu'il vaut mieux
monter sur scène le ventre vide ça c'est
une bonne question ah moi je monte
toujours sur scène le ventre vide mais
déjà on n pas envie d'avoir un rototo on
n pas envie d'avoir un truc en travers
de la gorge on n pas envie d'être
ballonné ou d'avoir un truc qu'on pas
non non et puis même il y a une question
de de de légèreté oui je bois beaucoup
de d'infusion d'eau chaude avant de faut
pas avoir envie d'aller aux toilettes
bah si si si mais c'est pas grave ça
dure 1 heure et dem le spectacle et on y
va après mais il faut boire faut boire
beaucoup boire beaucoup mais non manger
après ouais ouais for on a faim après ou
pas par ça dépend comment ça s'est passé
non alors on a faim plus tard on a faim
bien plus tard ouais ouais mais si si si
on a quand même faim ce que dit c'est ce
que dit l'humoriste dans le dans le
sketch il dit quand c'est pas bon quand
on quand quand on a fait un bide on a
besoin de manger pour se rassurer puis
quand c'était bien on a besoin de manger
pour se récompenser et vous êtes friand
de cette art du standup qui se développe
il y a le panamart café il y a eu Jamel
Comé ah ouais mais c'est ancien
ouais y a beaucoup beaucoup d'artistes
qui sont sortis de là ouais ouais bien
sûr bon c'est ouais si c'est bien bien
sûr ouais ouais c'est chouette je suis
pas cliente je je ne vais pas parce que
mais vous allez pas voir vos vos
collègues j'ai envie de dire enfin pas
on n pas confrère c'est il y a pas une
grande famille des humoristes ça existe
pas c'est très puis on est seul en scène
oui mais vous vous reconnaissez un peu
quand même non si vous vous voyez si
vous vous côtoyez il y a pas une petite
affinité parce que vous faites un peu M
vois pas de fait sauf quand on fait des
Comédy club comme là où on est ensemble
moi j'ai pas connu ça beaucoup à
l'époque où j'ai démarré où on faisait
ces ces bars il y avait Camille chamou à
l'époque il y avait des gens qu'on voit
plus il y avait ouais mais bon et vous
avez commencé j'ai vu avec Jamel Debou
aussi alors ça c'était l'improvisation
théâtrale et c'était au lycée à trrape
ouais ah oui il y a des vidéos qui
circulent en voit ou oui on était petit
ou tout petit déjà ou c'était en 91 les
trapistes les trapistes Anelka alors
Omar il avait Omar il avait pas fait
d'IMO il a démarré avec Jamel plus tard
et Anelka il a fait du foot oui oui
ouiussiguss j'ai fait du foot mais j'ai
pas fait carrière ouais vous auriez pu
he bah non non non alors le monde
d'après c'est une critique des
complotistes des antivax des WIS des
extrêmes on va écouter la bande annonce
et puis on en parle juste
après
[Musique]
il y a des racisés dans la salle je je
suis hyper contente non mais il y a
plein de racises et on me les AM mis
devant je suis trop contente que vous
soyez là ce soir
Namasté euh cœur sur vous et Vachin avec
les doigts mais moi par exemple à chaque
fois que je vais chez la gynéco la seule
question à laquelle j'ai droit j'ai
toujours droit à la même c'est et alors
est sympa à
Salamé si tous ceux qui se foutent de
leur gueule suc vraiment
Macron mais Macron il lui resterait plus
que des
coposin alors vous remarquerez que ça ne
marche qu'avec l'extrême droite non
jamais personne ne vous reprochera de
faire le jeu du MoDem par
exemple c'estolen royale elle a quand
même toujours été à la politique par ce
que la sodomie est à la reprodu
divertissante mais totalement
inutile est-ce qu'on peut rire de la
gauche non les genses droit
taisez-vous qu'est-ce qui vous agace le
plus finalement dans ce monde dans ce
monde d'après la liste est longue je
sais pas par quoi commencer oh en ce
moment je dirais la lâcheté peut-être et
puis les délires enfin je veux dire les
approximations le fait que les mots n'ai
plus de sens je continue allez-y mais
non il c'est c'est une accumulation de
choses c'est dernières années on a vu
quand même je sais pas autrefois on
débattait sereinement on pouvait avoir
des arguments et qui était fondé
aujourd'hui balancer quelque chose de
faux et si vous démontrez que l'argument
est faux mais c'est pas grave puisquil
suffit que l'autre en soit convaincu
pour que ça existe et pour que ce soit
légitime c'est quand même assez terrible
et puis la toute la culture de de la
victimisation
on est dans dans une époque du ressenti
c'est le ressenti qui compte plus que
tout et tout ça ça m'agace un peu cette
défense aussi des minorités là on a
l'impression que ça vous AG moi les
minorités j'ai toujours défendu et j'ai
toujours enfin c'est pas c'est pas une
défense des minorités c'est les les
discriminations les les inégalités tout
ça oui évidemment les injustices et pour
moi c'est tellement évidentjus mais il y
a une façon de de traiter ça c'està-dire
qu'aujourd'hui les personnes qui se
disent antiracistes confondent
l'antiracisme et la WWF c'estàd que j'ai
l'impression qu'on on considère les
minorités comme des petites choses
fragiles à protéger c'est assez
insupportable une espèce
d'archipélisation on pour dire ouais en
plus en plus ouais ouais qui est ass qui
est assez pénible c'est-à-dire que il va
falloir défendre que les que qu'on
défende les LGBT d'un côté qu'on
défendre les les les les musulmans de
l'autre qu'on défend les handicapés d'un
côté les femmes de l'autre mais il y a
pas de de volonté universel et moi je
suis assez universaliste et je pense
qu'on peut se s'approprier tous Cees
combat alors certains disent aujourd'hui
que vous êtes de Dr ça vous ça vous
agace vous est-ce que vous êtes pas
devenu RAC finalement à vous dire bah
tous ces gensl ça m'énerve tout ça ça
m'agace je pense pas je pense pas je
pense pas être de droite je pense que en
fait ce que je dis c'est que c'est
souvent la LFI qui me fait ce qui me
fait ce procès et de toute façon tout ce
qui est à la droite Desf et d'extrême
droite donc aujourd'hui les lignes pour
pour eux c'est ça moi j'ai pas bougé
d'un poil je suis toujours la même et je
pense vraiment être de gauche être
socialdémocrate et je pense pas que ce
soit un gros mot mais aujourd'hui quand
on dit qu'on est social démocrate
ben réblain profondément laïque
profondément républicaine féministe
écolo je suis sensible aux question
environnementale comme beaucoup et et
voilà donc oui oui je suis assez de
gauche ouais comme vous parliez de
postvérité d'archépilisation est-ce que
l'humour peut être un ciment ou
justement peut être une arme pour lutter
contre les fake news contre la post
vérité ça peut aider ou pas c'est celle
que j'ai choisi moi en les attaquant de
front et en foutant de leur gueule oui
oui oui je pense que çaen est mais après
la science doit être réhabilitée par les
scientifiques il faut laisser les
scientifiques avancer et continuer la
recherche et continuer de ne pas
opposer ben je sais pas des antivax à
des scientifiques sur des plateaux télé
par exemple ça ça pourrait aider mais
nous après de notre côté en tant
qu'humoriste B on est dans notre rôle
quand on se fout de leur gueule oui vous
dites que vous êtes féministe mais vous
vous moquez aussi des des féministes
dans votre spectacle ah c'est pas c'est
pas ne pas être féministe que se
de la gueule de certaines féministes
quand elles sont délirantes ouais oui
oui oui oui oui oui oui je peux me fout
de leur gueule oui mais il y a beaucoup
de féministes qui sont délirantes pour
vous ah bah ça peut aller très loin
c'estàdire que moi je pense que la
caricature enfin l'excès de certaines
est contreproductif et c'est ce que je
raconte dans le dans le spectacle moi je
pense qu'il faut continuer d'être
féministe tant qu'on sera pas arrivé à
l'égalité salariale tant qu'il y aura
autant de féminicide dans ce pays bah
ouais il faut continuer de se battre
mais est-ce qu'on prend les bonnes armes
pour se battre moment d'être excessif ça
peut pas faire avancer la cause à un
moment je crois je crois qu'il y a un
moment c'est pas c'est pas l'excès parce
que les excès ça a été nire en en 68 il
a fallu qui qu'il ait des propos
excessifs qu' ait des mouvements
excessifs mais l'excès peut aussi enin
surtout quand on est dans un corner dans
lequel on s'enferme je pense que c'est
l'enfermement qui est dangereux et
interdire aux autres de pouvoir parler
c'est interdire un homme de pouir parler
du féminisme je pense que les hommes on
a besoin d'eux dans cette lutte là ou
alors c'est Goolen royale alors pourquoi
c'est Golen royale mais on l'a perdu
c'est Golen royale c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est ver tigineux alors je sais
pas peut-être qu'on avait pas remarqué
avant mais c'est prise de position enfin
elle a quand même contesté le
bombardement de de la maternité de
marieoupul en disant on ne sait pas donc
dans la post vérité là on est à fond
puis elle est devenue chroniqueuse chez
Anana enfin je veux dire voilà elle est
elle est pro inutile pour vous ah ouais
non il faut arrêter quoi faut vraiment
arrêter et on a l'impression que vous
êtes plus antiinsoumis que
antirassemblement national est-ce que
vous vous trompez pas de cible ah non
non non non non non non non qu'on ne se
trompe pas de et en plus l'un n'empêche
pas l'autre c'est-à-dire que j'ai
toujours combattu l'extrême droite mais
toujours j'ai commencé à la radio en dem
allit combattre frontalement Jean-Marie
Le Pen Marine Le Pen et les électeurs du
rassemblement national en
2011 ça m'a coûté assez cher et sur les
réseaux sociaux ce matin encore hein je
suis allée en bloer qui me propose de
mettre des saucissons dans le derrière
donc eux ils se trompent pas ils savent
très bien que que que je les cible et
que je les les attaques en revanche ça
ne m'empêchera jamais d'attaquer les
insoumis quand ils sont délirants quand
ils refusent de dire que le Hamas est
une organisation terroriste quand ils
refusent de prendre des positions
claires et quand ils font du tort à la
gauche de mon point de vue quand ils ont
des positions qui ne sont pas claires
sur l'antisémitisme quand ils ont des
positions qui ne sont pas claires je
pense qu'il faut être clair et quand les
gens qui sont qui se disent de gauche ne
le sont pas sur Poutine sur sur les
vaccins surtout sur tellement de sujets
la liste est tellement longue que je ne
me priverai jamais de les combattre et
c'est pas parce que l'extrême droite est
est puissante aujourd'hui que je dois
m'interdire de combattre le la France
insoumise mais je continue de combattre
l'extrême droite de mon côté ça il y a
aucune ambigué et les deux ne sont pas
incompatibles on peut combattre les deux
la qualification d'humoriste politique
elle conviendrait pour vous ouais ouais
ça vous va et vous avez jamais eu envie
de vous engagé parce que vous êtes très
engagé dans dans vos dans vos spectacles
vous faire de la politique non je dis
ouais non la vi fait des réponses super
pénibles non non non non je je fais des
spectacles dans lesquels j'arrive à dire
plein de choses j'ai une liberté totale
je suis pas sûre que j'aurais la même
liberté si j'étais ça m'a jamais
effleuré l'esprit et je pense que je
suis très bien là où je suis et puis
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour la
fonction pour l'engagement politique et
tout ça c'est c'est c'est des choses qui
sont là et il y a jamais des politiques
qui sont venus vous chercher en vous
disant ah bah viens pour pour ma
campagne tu pour m'a bien sûr mais il
pense que c'est possible mais ça va pas
la tête quoi non non je veux pouvoir
leur taper dessus aussi donc c'est votre
indépendance ma liberté totale ouais
vous par pardon Jean-Pierre oui non
juste une petite question je ne parle
pas plus du spectacle mais de ce monde
d'après qui est aussi le nom de votre
spectacle comment vous le voyez ce monde
d'après vous êtes pessimiste on n pas on
n pas dans une
période se donnent des raisons d'espérer
il y a plein de livres qui sortent des
raisons d'espérer espoir vous êtes
plutôt pessimist moi alors moi j'ai un
autre livre c'était un roman de Chalom
oslander qui s'appelle l'espoir cette
tragédie et je je pense que les
optimistes sont des gens dangereux je
pense qu'il fa je suis assez d'accord
avec ah non moi je suis je suis pas très
optimiste mais je suis
combative voilà je je quelque part il
alors et ben voilà mais pour l'instant
on sent que c'est pas complètement
gagner donc il faut vraiment combattre
mais je des raisons de se réjouir
aujourd'hui il y en a pas M aujourd'hui
non pe peut-être demain mais à part un
bon plat de pâte à la sauce tomate vous
parliez de l'acheter au début de vos
propos vous avez dénoncé le sil des
artistes souvent on dit finalement mais
pourquoi il se mêleent de ça ou est-ce
qu'un footballeur doit vraiment avoir un
engagement est-ce que être artiste être
une personnage un personnage public ça
donne forcément le droit de s'exprimer
ou ça a forcément envie de s'exprimer
tenir un message politique c'est
vraiment de la liberté de chacun et je
j'impose à personne de s'exprimer ce que
j'ai dit dans la tribune c'était qu'il y
a des personnalités qui sont réputées
pour signer des tribunes à longueur de
journée pour tout et n'importe quoi quoi
et celles-ci on les a pas entendu après
le 7 octobre et j'ai trouvé ça dommage
j'ai trouvé ça triste et j'ai trouvé ça
inquiétant et c'est pour ça que je l'ai
dit et quand on m'a posé la question
hein c'était pas je suis pas allé faire
une tribune pour le dire hein on m'a
posé la question j'ai répondu sinon je
je serais pas aller leur dire allez-y
enfin voilà on m'a posé la question j'ai
répondu et j'ai dit ce que j'en pensais
je pense que quand les la situation est
grave enfin je sais pas j'imaginait que
ce qui s'est passé le 7 octobre 7
octobre était suffisamment grave pour
que ça crée un électrochoc
mondial il y a pas eu vous attendez il y
a pas eu mais ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui la la la la la situation en
Palestine est tellement grave aussi
qu'il faut aussi le dénoncer et l'un
n'empêche pas l'autre enfin voilà mais
c'est dommage je oui je pense qu'il y a
des personnes qui pourraient qui
pourraient apaiser la situation en
France en tout cas h alors là on a
besoin de se rassurer donc on va
s'accrocher à notre platpat et on va
revenir à l'alimentation vous êtes plus
de 2 % à être végétarien et oui comme
vous ça veut dire qu'en France on mange
encore beaucoup de produits carnets
qu'on retrouve à la carte des
restaurants un cass-etête pour les
antiviandes on en parle et on met les
pieds dans le
plat alors Brigitte dans ce restaurant
faubourg d'aiment c'est son nom on y
mange des rillettes des croquettes mais
ami carnivore ce qui n'est pas le votre
cas vous faites fausse route toutes ces
recettes sont sans viande donc végétal
mais avec un mantra la gourmandise c'est
un reportage non Carné de Elsa
mondingava et elzar le
conidek on prépare les croquettes
cochonnes et les ingrédients ça va être
champignon de Paris champignon crème et
du tofou fumé ensuite il y a des
échalotes confites et un petit bouillon
qui est mis en gelé pour pouvoir lier le
tout et oui dans ces croquette
il n'y a du cochon que dans le nom dans
ce restaurant pas de viande pas de de
poisson rien qui vient de l'animal tout
est végétal mais pafade assaisonnement
sauce cuisson un mot d'ordre la
[Musique]
gourmandise une certaine texture en
bouche comme un peu un pied de cochon
mais que ce soit vraiment très très
gourmand très très régressif mais en
végétal alors
excellent excellent pour le chef alors
allons vérifier en salle et les
croquettes cochon avec la sauce
ravigotte ça vraiment un goût très fumé
très prononcé on a vraiment la
l'impression de manger de la viande mais
il y a rien du tout il y a que des que
des légumes est-ce que c'est bon
délicieux Benoît et Marie sont séduits
par cette cuisine végane eux qui veulent
réduire leur consommation de viande sur
la carte à côté des croquettes un
carpachio de céleries ou des riettes de
lentill le but rassurer le client avec
des références connues tous les codes du
bistro c'est ça que je trouve
intéressant et en tout cas même dans la
façon voilà les morillettesite on p à de
la viande eten pas donc du coup je
trouve qu'il y un peu des trompil
intéressant dans dans C plat sur la
façon don proposer une cuisine durable
mais gourmande c'est l'objectif d'Alice
tu c'est vra qu'on pe avoette image de
laisine véé restrictive asétique un peu
tristoun enfin cuisine de de régime
alors qu'en fait non on peut faire
vraiment de la bonne bouffe avec de la
sauce avec du gras avec des textures
avec des plein de techniques de cuisson
et c'est vrai qu'on cherche à desffet de
surprise chez les clients parce que nous
en tant que restaurateur je pense
qu'aujourd'hui une de nos obligations
c'est vraiment de rendre désirable cette
durabilité et ça passe par cette cuisine
là qui est beaucoup plus édoniste que
celle qu'on pourrait imaginer quand on
pense végétal en France 150 restaurants
servent des menus exclus
végétarien ou
végan alors sopia une petite envie de
goûter une croquette
dit comme ça alors je vais je
suis joueuse parce que bah nous on est
joueur ici Brigitte allez allez merci
hein oh là
là c'est bon oui c'est du cochon sans
halouf voà mais c'est vrai que j'y
croyais pas trop en écoutant le
reportage il reste il restitue assez
bien le goût de la viande alors que il y
a du tofu des champignons c'est assez
assez fort vous trouvez alors moi je
sais pas j'ai pas mangé de viande depuis
que j'ai très je trouve j'aurais
peut-être à l'aveugle piliss prend alors
ça vaut pas un bon pied de cochon pané
mais je trouve que quand même c'est
assez gourmand quel enfire ce truc le
pied de cochon pan alors justement
est-ce que le fait de garder des noms
carnets riettes croquettes qui font
appel à des produits carnets est-ce que
c'est une bonne idée alors tout dépend
de la raison végétarien bah oui mais
tout dépend de la raison pour laquelle
vous devenez végétarien si vous devenez
vég rien alors que vous aimez la viande
j'imagine que ça doit être un truc
pareil de de de réconfort d'aller
rechercher des des des saveurs ou des
texture qui vous rappelle quelque chose
des appellations surtout Mo moi j'aime
pas la viande je cherche pas la viande
mais vous c'est par goût pourquoi c'est
depuis l'âge de 13 ans ouais 13 ans je
peux le dater parce que c'était j'étais
petite il y a eu un élément déclencheur
ouais ah il y a toujours un déclic dans
ces cas ben j'aimais pas ça d'abord
d'abord donc j'ai ça pas du tout été
difficile mais j'en mangeais pas
beaucoup j'aimais pas vraiment ça et
puis laïde au Maroc mon grand-père
égorge le le mouton et tout se passe
bien dans la mesure du possible mais
j'étais avec ma cousine et mon
grand-père on éétait que tous les trois
et là j'ai dû mettre les mains à la pâte
donc j'ai tout fait avec lui on ramassé
les abats on a pris les abats on a
nettoyé le sang avec ma cousine on a
grillé les pâtes de de de pas du cochon
mais du mouton et tout ça on a tout fait
et puis après quand ma cousine et moi on
a préparé les brochettes et quand on
s'est posé pour prendre les brochettes
avec le thé à la menthe comme on le fait
tradition iellement bah j'ai pas eu
envie d'en manger j'avais un petit peu
les yeux du mouton un petit peu triste
et puis le lendemain couscous avec le
mouton et non j'avais pas eu envie et là
je l'ai j'ai j'ai compris que j'en
voulais plus parce que je ne voulais
plus avoir à manger de viande en fait et
c'est plus du le bien-être animal en
fait c'est plus la souffrance de la bête
qui vous a il il y avait il y avait ça
il y avait je j'ai eu un rapport à la
bête comme ça qui m'a et puis ça
m'allait bien de ne pas manger de viande
je j'étais en en paix avec ça je me suis
je veux pas en manger j'en mange pas et
puis je j'ai fait attention à mon
alimentation j'essaie d'équilibrer je
mange encore un peu de poisson des
petits poissons pour pour avoir un peu
de protéine je mange des œufs je mange
ah oui donc pas tout à fait végétarien
comment on dit flexlexitarien non
flexitarien c'est quand on mange un peu
de viande pas de viande du tout mais
vous pas de viande du tout pas de viande
du tout du tout du tout du tout donc
mais en revanche je ne donc je ne vais
pas chercher un truc qui ressemble à de
la viande j'ai pas envie d'aller manger
des des cotelettes de tofu des riettes
de che pas ouis non ça ça vous fait pas
particulièrement VI non ça m'excite pas
beaucoup mais mais en revanche je
comprends si c'est quelqu'un qui aimait
la viande et qui a arrêté par conscience
environnementale ou ou pour le bien-être
animal et qui se disent B quand même
j'aimais bien manger des burgers mais
alors c'est pas de pas complètement le
respect du vivant puisque votre histoire
de de ce mouton puisque vous mangez les
poissons qui sont vivants et vous
acceptez de les voir morts dans votre
assiette je mange pas vivant non mais
vous acceptez de les des manger grillés
des sardines c'est ben c'estàdire que
c'est compliqué de de d'équilibrer son
alimentation sans avoir de protéin
animal donc je mange des œufs et un peu
de poisson et et ouais ben en fait c'est
c'est je sais c'est un peu je les
regarde pas dans les yeux les poissons
quand quand je les quand je lesais dans
chez le poissonnier mais il y a une
petite il y avait quand même beaucoup de
plats à base de viande que ce soit le
couscous les tagines et ça ça posait des
des problèmes dans la famille on a tout
de suite accepté non ça faisait plus
pour les autres et et mon père continue
de me proposer de la viande aujourd'hui
encore il se dit on sait jamais je peux
changer d'avis ça peut revenir il pas
capitulé non non il lâche pas l'affaire
eu vous vous trouvez que vous avez le
choix vous dans les restaurants parce
que quand on est végétarien aujourd'hui
à la carte c'est souvent un peu c'est un
peu maigre quoi il y a pas toujours
beaucoup de non on trouve toujours et
d'ailleurs quand je suis invité quelque
part même chez des amis je le dis pas en
général j'aime pas le dire parce que
j'aime pas imposer une contrainte et
puis les gens se cassent la tête alors
qu'en fait il suffit de pousser la
viande et de manger les légumes
l'accompagnement et il y a toujours une
solution vraiment mais c'est pas très
fun du coup vous tapez tous les légumes
et puis euh c'est bien les légumes mais
si c'est très bien les légumes non non
ça me dérange pas du tout et puis et
puis c'est ma contrainte à moi j'aime
pas l'imposer à à tout le monde et et en
fait mon mari commence à en avoir marre
quand on mange végétarien partout où on
va et déjà à la maison donc quand il
sort il aime bien aussi avoir un peu de
viande comme votre père il vous dit
mange de la viande ça peut
arriver non mais puis surtout c'est
c'est c'est il y a pas de dogmatisme
dans mon dans dans mon rapport à la
viande c'est je veux pas que ce soit une
contrainte pour les autres donc à la
carte non je trouve toujours mon bonheur
je mange des et les légumineuses vous
justement vous compensez un peu le
manque de protéin par par ça ouais bien
sûr bien sûr c'est vachement important
surtout des lentilles du quinoa aussi ou
des le quinoa c'est pareil hein c'est
pas un truc foufou c'est ce qu'on va
mettre avec le quinois mais c'est plus
pour remplacer le riz les pâtes et tout
ça mais non non les légumineuses surtout
là en avec l'entrée dans l'hiver j'adore
ça j'admire votre côté consignant parce
que moi je trouve que ça se radicalise
quand même maintenant les vég arien les
végétaliens il font pas de concession
hein vous les invitez s'il y a s'il y a
de la viande si c'est un peu touché de
viande ils n'en veulent pas vous trouvez
pas qu'il y a quand même une radicalité
qui s'inscrit aussi à table comme en
politique ou comme ailleurs peut-être
que c'est un passage je pense qu'il y a
un moment où on est en train de
découvrir ces problématiques là on est
en train d'en prendre la mesure
peut-être que voilà ça ça va se calmer
bon après c'est beaucoup les jeunes qui
sont comme ça puis les jeunes sont dans
leur rôle de nous bousculer de nous de
nous de nous demander un petit peu de de
nous remuer sur ces les jeunes qui
peuvent dire non à la viande et pu
manger de la malbouffe à côté ex
exactement mais à la fois est-ce qu'on n
pas content que nos jeunes se Mobilis
sur ces sujets là et prennent
conscience là où nous on a peut-être pas
été à la hauteur donc c'est plutôt bien
qu'il s'en par de ces sujetsl je pense
que c'est aussi à nous d'être un peu un
peu conciliant de faire un pas vers eux
aussi mais c'est vrai que c'est devenu
plus compliqué la table aujourd'hui
entre végétarien végétalien végan sans
gluten sans lact et les
allergiques mais c'est compliqué en fait
d'inviter les gens de se réunir ah bah
si vous mangez cacher si vous mangez à
l'AL si vous avez dans une tablée si
vous cumulez les allergies les
intolérants et les restrictions
religieuses alors là on n pas rendu
rendu alors que la table en principe
c'est une façon facile de se réunir ça
devient un petit peu plutt ch alors le
plat de pâte dans ce cas c'est pas mal
mais ENF des pâtes sans gluten il y a du
gluten après il y en a qui vont nous
dire que les tomates sont pas de saison
si il y a toujours un toujours un moyen
de disc à maintenant alors qu'avant
c'était assez fédérateur aujourd'hui
c'est assez diviseur finalement oui je
pense que quand même on se retrouve on
aime beaucoup manger on reste français
on reste attaché à la gastronomie les
les émissions de cuisine vous avez une
émission dans laquelle on mange ça dit
quelque chose quand même sur notre
rapport à la bouffe alors on va passer
au dessert comme ça on va tous se mettre
d'accord puisque tout le monde a fini
qu'il est arrivé je l' vu c'est le péché
mignon alors voici le temps du sucré
avec un gâteau au chocolat et dans cette
trilogie gourmande moelleux fondant mi
au chocolat et bien on a droit à un
moelleux alors je sais pas si c'est
celui que vous aimez le plus il faut
bien savoir que le moelleux c'est celui
qui est le plus cuit le fondant est
encore moins cuit et le coulant est
encore moins moins cuit puisque
normalement quand on l'ouvre il est
coulant à cœur mais j'ai l'impression
que on nous a vendu un coulant un
coulant un moelle coulant pour un pour
unou alors est-ce qu'il est bon mais
surtout vous vouliez du chocolat mais
alors surtout Brigitte sopia avait dit
surtout pas de crème anglaise pas de
crème anglaise vous n'avez pas cette
crème anglaise qu'on qu'on colle partout
un peu ouais je vois pas vous aimz le
chocolat pur comme ça h
si c'est bon c'est bon mais ouais la
crème anglaise je vois pas l'intérêt
pourquoi on a eu l'idée de mettre de la
crème anglaise sur les desserts comme ça
ça gâché c'est bon la crème anglaise et
le gâteau au chocolat c'est bon mais les
deux ensemble ouis plutôt sur l'île
flotante quoi oua il y a des modes comme
ça on met beaucoup de crème anglaise
puis autre chose c'est comm ça ou même
le caramel je vois pas l'intérêt mais le
caramel et le chocolat donc vous les met
sous toutes ses formes moelleux coulant
fondant les petits carrets de chocolat
vous manger moi j'ai une recette de
gâteau au chocolat mousse sans farine on
fait cuire au bain marie ah c'est h
ouais on fait cuire une heure au bain
marie et c'est délicieux si N c'est
entre le gâteau et la mousse au
chocolatou c'est mousse cuite c'est
vraiment très très bon et ça se sert
chaud ou chaud avec avec crème fouettée
là pour le coup c'est
TRG la crème angla non non avec une
crème fouettée c'est VRAIMENT COCHON
comme dessert alors là c'est vraiment
que du sucre et du gras mais mais mais
c'est très très très très bon et c'est
le seul dessert que vous mangez c'est le
seul dessert que j'arrive à peu près à
faire que j'ai réussis à peu près non j'
j'en mange B en fait j'aime bien
terminer avec une petite note de sucre
et le chocolat je trouve que c'est
tellement bon et c'est pareil ça apporte
du réconfort faitcoup de réconfort dans
cette de la pâtisserie avec vos enfants
alors j'ai un fils qui a 24 ans et on
fait des gâteaux on faisait des gâteaux
yaourt avec lui quand il était petit
voilà le gâteau au yaourt du dimanche la
première expérience de pâtisserie pour
nous tous ouais le gâteau au yaourt
c'est c'est une valeur sûre pu c'est pas
trop difficile à faire c'est dans mes
c'est complètement dans mes cordes je
maîtrise je maîtrise parfaitement le
gâteau yaourt et j'aime bien pareil
encore dans ces trucs de réconfort
j'aime bien l'odeur du gâteau dans la
maison le dimanche il y a un truc qui va
bien sur Petit Gris oui ouai il y a un
truc avec un petit thé on a envie de de
se mettre sous un PL de manger bah la
boisson chaude et les desserts marocains
les bac alors alors
les non pas c'est pas marocain ah la
boulette la boulette alors la boulette
oui mais baclava non on a besoin de
précision on mange pas au Maroc des
baclavas on en mange par que c'est quand
même ouais on mange des trucs à base de
cherche et moi il me semblait qu'on en
trouvait mais mange on mange des cornes
de Gazell on mange plein de Sablé à base
d'amande et tout ça mais alors on les
mange pas en dessert d'accord on les
mange avec le
thé PL goû ouais à plusieurs moments
dans la journée hein ça peut être 10h
11h mais après le après le repas parfois
on va servir des fruits éventuellement
mais on mange pas de desser on n pas
cette culture là comme la paâtisserie
française non et dans pas mal de pays
arabes j'ai remarqué le dessert c'est
pas c'est très c'est très européen les
salades d'orange là un peu à
la plutôt fruit quoi fruits il y a des
pâtisseries au dates aussi qui sont
bonnes au Maroc nonvez pas ça les ouais
c'est ça avec le petit sourire comme ça
ça ça l'air bon c'est bon mais alors là
il y a gros conflit entre les Marocains
et les Tunisiens parce que les Tunisiens
disent qu'ils les font mieux que les
Marocains et voilà mais bon il y a
toujours mais c'est vrai que j'en ai
mangé à qui était exceptionnel et et au
Maroc ils sont bon aussi je veux pas
fâcher moi je veux fâcher personne m est
d'accord sur les pâtisseries on fâchera
personne merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivi et on se retrouve bien sûr la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de politique à table sur LCP